[Music]
let's go to melissa in
saint joe mo what's up melissa how are
you doing
oh not too shabby how you doing
same not too i'm going to start can i
steal that from you not too shy
absolutely yes all right not too shabby
melissa what's up
so i stumbled upon some information um
the other day that kind of now has me in
a quandary so um
what'd you stumble on
so i was looking online i was showing
one of my friends
online where you can look up
registered sex offenders
and saw a familiar face um my
daughter's best friend's dad
is on this list oh crap
yeah she there's seven
um god and
so i
of course did some googling digging and
basically the
he was 22
talking online with what he thought was
a 14 year old girl that ended up being a
cop
yeah so and
still went to meet like at the wendy's
or whatever and got busted
it was in 2007 so i mean it's been
a long time and i haven't seen anything
since then like online it basically says
that
you know he's in good standing or
whatever
um
i also know well i also i have a social
work background so i know the recidivism
rates and things like that are what
though
are horrible horrible and just so in
case people don't know what the word
recidivism means what does that mean
it means that they do it again the
chances i'm doing again is a bazillion
percent right
so
i don't want to punish the child for the
sins of the father but i also obviously
need to protect my daughter
um so you are not punishing anybody dad
is
you are not punishing
anybody
at all
what's the quandary here
i have a six-year-old almost almost
six-year-old daughter so we're in this
like i'm trying to put myself in your
shoes
and my blood is boiling it's like what's
the what's the what's the quandary
basically like
just to completely cut ties or just
because i have no idea this we don't
know the family all that well i i really
like mom i've rarely ever spoken to dad
um
and like my husband even brought up well
what if she doesn't know and i'm like
am i
i assumed that she knew but i mean who
knows so
just
you know just start ignoring
calls or just say look i found this out
so we're done
set you know do some safety planning and
say look she can come to my house but
we're not going to your house or you
know like just what
it's like i have a social work
background i've helped people safety
plan but it's different when it's your
kid it is it is it is and so i am
so i'll tell you a quick story
i won't tell you a quick story that
would take too long because i always say
i'll tell you a quick story then it's
like 45 minutes later and kelly's passed
out to sleep on the control board over
there
what i'll tell you is i've been in a
couple situations like in a crisis
response or i'm looking and thinking huh
i probably i don't know what's going on
here
and then somebody one of my partners
will roll up and be like what are you
doing call 9-1-1 or get the you know
what i mean so like you get so close to
it
that you
you lose perspective
right and so what i will tell you
is the last person
on the planet i would allow my daughter
to be in proximity to
is a registered sex offender with a
history of preying on young women young
girls right right agreed with an
exclamation point at the end of that
sentence
so
everything you choose to do after that
is in service to
my daughter will never be around a known
sex offender if i have any breath in my
lungs period
and so whether you choose to sit down
with wife
and say
here's the deal i learned this i know
our daughters are friends i don't care
what story y'all are gonna give me
there can be no possible way my daughter
is in your home is in a car with you
y'all i mean
you can do that that would be the a plus
hyper integris
gentle direct but loving way to say
i learned new information and the
relationship between us and our kids is
different
or
man there's seven and the world gets
busy things get bananas do they live
across the street from you they down the
road i mean how
pretty much
so
they actually they used to go to the
same school then covet hit and things
change so they don't actually go to the
same school anymore
um
but
that was her
her close friend from that school and
we've continued to have play dates and
things like that and then to add another
layer of like
weirdness and ick is so we
basically joined a particular chapter of
a local community group that's based
around kids because that family is in
this chapter
dude
he's not allowed to be around kids
so yeah i don't know what all the
i'm telling populations are he doesn't
get to be around kids
and if there is some sort of way they
finagled themselves around a lot of kids
i would throw every flag on planet earth
i would turn on every light and hit
every siren
i'd call every probation officer i could
that's that's i mean that's your job as
a community member
or to go directly to them
and ask wife
your husband is a registered sex
offender and best i can tell
he was preying on a young girl and went
to meet her
how are you all involved in a local
community group that's revolved around
children
walk me through how this works
that's the kind i'm confrontational in
that way my wife is especially
um
but
yeah this one's bigger than even your
kid that's not a complicating factor
that is like a gasoline on a fire factor
and so you've heard me say this before
on the show and i'll say it again not by
your hand but in your lap
this isn't your fault this isn't
something that you caused or sought out
well you did when you started googling
but it dropped in your lap and thank god
it did that it happened to drop in the
lap of a social worker
who knows how incredibly damaging this
thing can be
and
man this has all you know i just saying
it out loud you know this has all the
makings of oh no
right
yes
like and then when you found out oh
they're in this group and then oh my oh
my like the puzzle pieces start going
together even if it's totally
interesting the snowball just started
rolling yes
so what i'm telling you and i'm putting
you in an unfair position but i didn't
do it the cosmos did it i'm just calling
it out
you have to say
everything
as loud as you can
whether that's looking up the probation
officer whether that's calling your
local
police department to get some more
information
whether that's notifying the
the umbrella agency of this community
group
whether that's going directly to their
home and saying my daughter has been in
your house
what in the world
y'all didn't tell us
how and how in the world
yeah i
again
friends will come and go your daughter's
seven she's gonna have a million friends
you're gonna break up with half of them
the other half's gonna move away you
know i mean that's life
just imagine yours
your daughter's life
three years from now you say no it's
fine it was a long time ago ten years
ago he seems fine
and something is nefarious is going on
i'd never forgive myself
yeah and that's just you thinking about
you i'm thinking about your daughter
like what's our one job as parents keep
our kids safe
absolutely not to protect them from all
the harm i mean from stubbing their toes
and falling down and getting f's i'm all
about that
but this one
we got one job on this one
so what's your next move melissa and
again i'm walking alongside you because
i know you're so far in this
it's like oh no
and it is that big
but the world needs melissa's to turn
all the lights on and say no no no no
not on my watch not my daughter not my
neighborhood not my daughter's friends
cause my daughter is everybody's
daughter and everybody's daughter's my
daughter and i'm calling this one out
so what's your next move what's what are
you gonna do today
um well i mean i can definitely look
into you know who
whoever is providing supervision over
the whole thing and
i like it to try to figure out with our
family like okay do we say
you know she can come here but that's it
melissa
or just completely cutting ties is
basically where i'm at like which
because it's cutting ties is doable
especially since they don't even attend
the same school anymore that like okay
so that's that's like part one a d
like way down the list
that's solving little problem
well and getting into i obviously yeah i
have no problem with getting in touch
with the community organization in
question and making sure that
even if you call and say my daughter's a
part of this group and you have a
registered sex offender as a leader in
this group or a part of this group what
are you doing
yeah
well and i'm
i mean you know what to do when you
assume my assumption is they
i had no clue and i've known these
people longer than this community group
has
so
i'm assuming they're going to go
holy crap
yeah because i am and i don't i don't
even know what community i have no
i had no clue
how how long have you how long have you
known them
three years
do you have a good enough relationship
with that wife just to call and say this
is mom to mom what in the world what the
crap
can you do that
i mean i could do it i don't know that i
would like she's not a close friend by
any stretch of the imagination we text
when we're getting the girls together
but that's about the extent of it but
you're not gonna say anything are you
oh no
i know you don't know me but i'm not i'm
an ad advocate at heart like that's i
i'm just trying to figure out whether
it's better just to completely just to
basically
throw gas in the fire throw the bomb
walk away
say this is not okay and just cut ties
and then have to explain it to my
daughter when she's older
or
whether it would be at all feasible for
you know play dates just at my house or
something like that so like i said i i
feel bad for his daughter because it's
not her fault but that's not your
problem to solve
that's th that's a bed that he created
your job is not to create a fun
environment for his daughter
that's that's that's
that is a situation they're gonna have
to handle
you're trying to control too much
i feel bad for his daughter too i'm
brokenhearted for her i am devastated
for her
because this is gonna happen over and
over in her life
that she's gonna make close friends and
then it's gonna get out
um and then they're gonna be a mess i
can't imagine they're allowed to have
other kids too at their house
well in the day that i found this out
she had my daughter had spent basically
the whole afternoon with their family on
that like two days before that
have you done a
have you done a forensic interview on
your daughter
yes
and she's okay
well dad was it was
just my friend siblings mom out riding
bikes dad was at work so he wasn't even
around
so just to cut to it if this is my
daughter yes this relationship is over
until further notice period full stop
conversation's over
and if
um
again i'm gonna make that call and say
hey can we meet out and just meet out in
the front yard for a minute um
i want to make sure everything's okay
i'll make sure my daughter y'all didn't
hurt my daughter
and i'm upset that
you didn't disclose this
when my daughter started coming to your
house and i found out about it this way
they had a responsibility to tell you if
this is hanging over you know what i
mean so think about it this way if i got
arrested for stealing money and it was
10 years ago
and then i'm getting a job with somebody
i need to say hey by the way this is in
my background here's what actually
happened here's the truth of the last 10
years and here's who i am and where i am
now
i have a moral and ethical obligation to
put that out there
and if you're on the sex offender
registry list for soliciting young girls
and then going to try to visit with them
and thank god it was a cop and not an
actual 14 year old
right and
then my seven-year-old just starts going
to play at your house oh
no
no oh no no
and you're going to join a community
group that's got a lot of kids around
no
dude i'm calling including including 14
year old girls no
no no
something's not right here i can't
imagine somebody's at brazen except
people are
yeah unbelievable yes every single alarm
goes off
conversation's over
either have the conversation with her
i'm calling the community group today
today
if mom texts and says hey we haven't
seen you in a while um can so-and-so
come and play and you write back no she
can't come play today thank you so much
and she says hey is there a problem say
hey yeah let's chat if she invites you
in great
but this is your moment well let's say
you've been an advocate and a lot of
advocacy these days happens on the
internet or a lot of advocacy happens
like going to like um like fundraisers
and things
this is advocacy right now
you got to go through me to get to my
daughter and these kids in this
neighborhood you got to go through me
and my
husband and my team and my profession
because ad real advocacy costs us
something because it can get us hurt
real advocacy is a pain and it it comes
at a cost and this is your moment
melissa to stand up for your daughter
for all the daughters
and for
god almighty dude
sheesh
thanks for the call melissa do it do it
hey
you owe us now
after you make your calls i want you to
let us know how it goes call back to the
show and let us know
man man man kelly i'm having a good
attitude huh
i haven't said any bad words i haven't
walked off uh we've said a few in here
i've set him for you i
holy smokes
all right
dude
imagine this america i'm speechless
this is a rare moment
i'd like to welcome everybody
to the moment of speechless